não importo com estreitos seja o portão
o com repleto de castigo seria sentença
eu sou o dono do meu destino eu sou o
capitão da minha alma
esse poema se chama invicto e eu escutei
pela primeira vez aos 20 e poucos anos
de idade e quando eu descobri que ele
foi inspiração a nelson mandela e seus
27 anos de reclusão na prisão ele fazia
tanto sentido para minha vida como se
tivesse sido escrito diretamente pra mim
sou nascido e criado no subúrbio do rio
de janeiro no bairro do engenho de
dentro e houve uma série de jovens muito
parecidos comigo virarem estatísticas se
perder no meio do caminho negro pobre
com uma construção família um pouco
diferenciada
eu perdi meu pai muito novo com dois
anos de idade a violência das favelas do
rio de janeiro por estar no local errado
na hora errada e com as pessoas erradas
também era um jovem com um futuro
brilhante pela frente mas acabou
perdendo a sua vida com 26 anos de idade
sem culpa e sem chance de se defender
por conta disso foi criado pela minha
madrinha dos dois anos de idade até os
seis anos de idade e isso não é o círio
lutada foi um período da minha vida em
que eu sofri uma série de agressões
físicas e morais a mais absurda que eu
lembro até hoje foi uma garrafada que eu
tomei esse lado aqui no supercílio
só que eu não queria comer um pedaço de
bife porque tinha muita gordura
a gente foi despejado com cristian e
sete anos de idade e tem aquela máxima é
o pobre que não tinha nada mas perdeu
tudo mas a gente perdeu tudo é casa o
meu cachorro brinquedo e saímos de uma
mochilinha nas costas pra ter que morar
em casa de favor de pessoas que a gente
conhecia para poder segurar um pouco a
barra
naquele momento pude perceber que eu
tinha todas as possibilidades para dar
errado na vida mas 25 anos depois hoje
eu posso perceber que eu tenho uma
profissional de sucesso eu tenho uma
carreira que eu desejei mas não pela
quantidade de grana que eu consegui
juntar ou pela quantidade de cursos
graduações conseguiu fazer nem a
quantidade de país eu consegui visitar
mas a quantidade de oportunidades que eu
consegui aproveitar a minha vida das
pequenas às grandes oportunidade
oportunidade muitas vezes que passam
desapercebidos aos olhos das pessoas que
não estão dispostas a enxergar essa
oportunidade oportunidade por exemplo de
aprender por todos os lugares que passei
na minha vida como por exemplo a casa do
vovô seu casaca
a gente sempre brincava falando que o
imóvel tinha uma casa legitimamente
suburbana
era uma casa grande número de subúrbio a
porta ficava aberta as pessoas entrarem
saiu hoje dava todo mundo que passava
por lá
minha mãe fala que no final dos anos 70
um senhor bateu em casa com uma boquinha
de alumínio pedindo comida
não vou colocar para dentro de casa
cortou o cabelo deu comida fez a barba
quando um pouco melhor à mesma mesa que
a família da família da gente porque ele
informa que chamada jesus e que ele não
poderia perder a oportunidade de ajudar
um novo messias só na cabeça dele e eu a
minha avó ela vem do rio grande do sul
com os pais dela que acabaram criando
ela ela foi mãe solteira e teve que
trabalhar desde muito cedo e eu sempre
como faxineiro empregada passadeira e
por ter que trabalhar e trazer comida
para casa ela teve que deixar os dois
filhos que ela teve em casas separadas
para poder trabalhar e e e fazer um
corre do dia d na casa do seu casaco foi
à casa onde nuno pai ele cresceu e
casaca crio no pai como se fosse mais um
dos quatro filhos que ele teve foi
adotado com oito anos de idade em por
uma das filhas do seu casaca que era
carinhosamente chamada de negra e vocês
é a minha vida ela mudou bastante desde
esse momento
não falo que eu sair da condição de um
moleque de bd comunidade porque na época
morava na baixada fluminense com tio era
a única pessoa que conseguiu ficar
comigo naquele momento o médico passou a
ter tudo na vida
isso tudo é muito pouco para casa comida
roupa lavada e ninguém para espancar dia
sim dia não para mim aquela era a minha
oportunidade
a oportunidade eu entendo como não algo
pronto preparado que você consuma e que
bata à sua porta para que você usa no
dia-a-dia a oportunidade de um
entendimento ela faz parte de um
processo de construção
eu faço parte desse processo de
construção
quando a minha mãe me adotou ela notou
uma criança que era gordinha uma criança
que era é nutrida ela uma criança com
uma série de problemas psicológicos
uma série de problemas por conta da sua
primeira infância que foi muito difícil
a criança cardiopata
mas independente do tipo de trabalho que
ela deveria ter poder de transformar em
alguém na vida ela agarrou com
residência mudou minha vida eu tinha uma
relação muito boa com a minha mãe quer
uma relação que ela ultrapassar uma
relação de firma em uma relação de
amizade muito grande com a minha mãe eu
sempre digo que ela foi minha melhor
amiga de sempre e não era nem passava
muitos ensinamentos e uma coisa que ela
falava que eu levei pro resto da vida é
que ela me criava para que eu me
tornasse um preto sim senhor e não um
preto voz me ser isso ela dizia porque
ela era muito estava muito com relação
às formas que eu falava que eu me vestia
que eu lidava com as outras pessoas que
ela dizia que eu deveria ser um exemplo
em outra coisa que ela falava é que ela
não tinha nenhum tipo de herança para me
dar casa dinheiro carro mas a herança
que ela me daria a possibilidade do por
estudar eu poder me desenvolver através
dos estudos
essa seria a maior herança que ela daria
pra mim
mal ela sabia ou de repente
indiretamente sabendo ela repassava a
seguinte mensagem que num país como o
brasil que gera uma série de restrições
para quem nasce negro pobre em áreas
comunidade ou em área de subúrbio
estudar seria um ato de rebeldia que eu
poderia ter contra qualquer tipo de
sistema mediante isso eu acabei me
formando eu fiz duas graduações de
marketing administração eu fiz mba em
uma das melhores universidades do brasil
fiz tensão
universidade da califórnia vai e voltei
fiz mestrado na universidade federal
fluminense o doutorando pela
universidade federal fluminense
se me fazer chorar antes da hora
eu entendo meu próprio negócio é uma
marca de roupa masculina e feminina que
tem como conceito principal a cultura
suburbana se a cultura suburbana que eu
vivi a vida toda e que hoje eu
transformei numa oportunidade de negócio
em 2012 quando eu comecei a pesquisar e
desenvolver a marca eu percebi que a
maior parte das marcas que tinham no
mercado carioca trabalhava no mercado
carioca como se fosse restritamente a
zona sul
é como se não existisse outra parte do
rio de janeiro e eu como nunca fui de
papel todo dia passar para a final no
cabelo pega onda eu percebi que eu tenho
90% da população carioca que não morasse
no centro na zona sul
poderia ter a mídia o mesmo anseio que a
mesma necessidade de existir uma marca
de roupa que tivesse uma boa costura uma
boa estampa mas que retratasse a sua
cultura local ea sua identidade
por isso a gente desde 2012 vem
praticamente todos os estados do brasil
através da nossa loja online através do
nosso onde fica na zona norte do rio
iremos por outro lado do mundo no japão
onde nós temos a nossa primeira revenda
autorizada da marca
e aí é muito engraçada como é que a
gente poderia imaginar uma marca que
saiu do subúrbio do rio e do rio de
janeiro do engenho de dentro da adolfo
bergamini do meu quarto poderia atingir
o outro lado do mundo o cliente que
nunca imaginei na minha vida atingir
eu sempre falo que ultimamente tem feito
não só para o meu desenvolvimento
pessoal toda essa correria que eu falei
pra vocês
desde o meu primeiro momento da primeira
infância dirigir todo esse sofrimento
que eu passei tudo mais
eu faço muito hoje para mostrar a
algumas pessoas que é possível se chegar
a algum lugar
a mãe sempre falava que eu teria de ser
duas vezes melhor
eu falo para vocês se é difícil você tem
que ser 30 vezes melhor
esse é um pensamento que eu tenho eu
falo com as pessoas que acreditam de
repente que o seu portão esteja muito
estreito
ou então que o seu caminho seja muito
penoso existe uma chave para você
conseguir chegar a algum lugar e as
chaves chama o conhecimento conhecimento
é poder
eu desde 2012 a área mas já não está
mais entre nós
ela fez a sua passagem não está mais
nesse mundo físico mas não faço muito em
tributo a ela também porque acredito que
independente de onde ela estiver
ela está muito orgulhosa por tudo que
ela conseguiu ajudar a criar na minha
vida tudo legado que ela deixou
e aquele moleque pequenininho que todo
mundo rejeitou desde a aparente mãe
biológica ela estendeu a mão e ela mudou
a minha vida
então queria dedicar essa minha fala a
minha mãe dona luca ea por tudo que ela
fez por mim muito obrigado